it's a normal day looking forward to
find and we've had a good day and
wanting to go Robin
having having crack you know the banter
between the lads as always normal day
and then we've got outside and I'll
brothers police officer being attacked
by the knife man it was shot and killed
he was repeatedly stabbing him he didn't
intend to hurt anyone didn't tend to
wound then one he was trying to kill the
officer that's the only that's in word
for it you know did it was savage what
happened next
amongst all madness it sort of it was
one there's one like calm figure and
that was the armed police officer you
know I wasn't guesses I mean I say it's
trained in this situation I don't think
anyone's trained for that situation I
don't think you can replicate that sort
of situation anywhere anyhow but he was
a very professional calm and sure walk
through the mud crowd towards towards
the attacker the attackers walk walking
forward both hands knife and he pulled
out his pistol and and placed two in the
photos chest this video is only about
sin 7 seconds long isn't it but actually
you can see quite lucky talking yeah if
you slow it down you can see obviously
there's my teammate Pat McCormack I'm
one of my trainer Tony Davis this police
officers here running away from the
attacker and he see Leon uniformed
police officer and the attacker walking
towards him and you can hear the two
shots fired
he did wat today if he didn't if he
didn't take that bullet if he didn't
pull the gun out and give the guy two
bullets then all the people water die
I'm sure of it
the police commander said you're gonna
be near for a while we need to get to
the fellows core because there's an
unidentified package in there to the
panic in the room I just fought on edge
I mean everyone is around me I was
having a bit of an anxiety panic stuff I
was thinking you know what's going on
there's people screaming people crying
all around you anyone was it was in
arm's length he was gonna do damage to
you because the coward that is he was
there to you know to try and put fear
into the people of England the people in
London that's that's what he was trying
to do he's trying to put fear into
everyone but unfortunately for him it
didn't work because as much as these
people think make it they can do this
the next day you know as a country as a
united nation we go on